more than 70 years ago a British man
took a wooden broomstick and crafted a
toy for his young child and Thomas the
Tank Engine was born his creation later
inspired books movies and a very popular
TV series that airs in a hundred and
sixty-one countries and territories in
some 57 languages but despite that
incredible popularity the franchise is
getting a major update in an effort to
appeal to even more children the world
over Roxana Saberi has the story
Thomas burst onto screens in the 80s and
with a little help from narrator Ringo
Starr the blue engines adventures became
an instant hit Thomas thinks no engine
works as hard as he does he loves
playing tricks on them Thomas and his
friends changed through the decades but
in more than 500 episodes some things
stayed the same
the trains never left the Island of
Sodor and a female character is barely
in the spotlight I don't want to puff to
maithwaite to collect the stinky washing
we know that we've got a show that means
a lot to young audiences and really what
we're trying to do is just bring that
show into 21st century and make it
relatable for that young audience
Ian McHugh and Michaela winter are part
of the creative team overhauling Thomas
& Friends
the makeover comes with an updated theme
song international travels and two new
female main characters Rebecca and Nia
Africa is a wonderful country is not a
country Tomas Africa is a continent
we've always had female characters but
bringing them to the forefront of the
show is really important having that
real kind of range and diversity I think
is really important so that everyone can
watch the show and think oh you know
that person's like me that characters
like me and I feel represented if about
half of Thomas's fan base are girls why
did it take so long to have a main
female character what happens is we sort
of create a nuclear metal canister she's
in two or three episodes and then in the
next season she'll sort of disappear
into the background while we bring in
the newer characters so I think that was
a fault of our owns that we wanted to
sort of rectify and that's why we
decided that what we needed to do is
actually move out to other boys and
bring in two new girls the team wanted
Nia a Tank Engine from Kenya to be
authentic I said that's you I used two
animals on the tracks the character is
voiced by Yvonne Grundy a Kenyan born
English actress Nia was developed in
partnership with the United Nations
through Nia were able to see an African
character really taken up a leadership
role as a female train engine with lots
of strong values and goals herself five
UN sustainable development goals
including gender equality were weaved
into storylines with the help of two
Lupe Lewis Tomoka of u and women their
stereotypes out there around the road
that a girl should play and different
from that that boy should be but through
the character Nia we're able to simplify
it by showing that you know a female
engine has skills and abilities and can
actually get the job done just like a
male
engine Thomasson France has over 1
billion YouTube channel views but
viewership is not necessarily translated
into sales for Mattel the company
acquired the franchise six years ago for
680 million dollars but sales for the
fisher-price and Thomas and Friends
brands were down 14% due in part to
lower sales of Thomas products I'd
better work extra hard if I want to fit
in hey for these engines the keys to
staying relevant may be inclusion and
girl power how do you think these
changes will help ensure Thomas's future
for another 70 some years I think the
changes we're making will make the show
sort of relatable fryer audience though
watching it today but I kind of feel
like it's a natural show that's going to
go on for another 70 years you know it's
it's so cool that he's trained he's a
character he's going around the world
he's teaching our young audience lessons
there are other ways to get animals to
move Thomas without scaring them yeah
he'll be here for for many years to come
back that track will keep on ongoing for
CBS this morning Saturday Roxana Saberi
London
[Music]